an important anniversary is approaching
this Tuesday polish soldiers will be
marching to commemorate their 1920
victory over the Soviets Red Army but
with current day hostilities as many as
10 000 troops are being handed new
orders
we have to be ready for any scenario
explained the Polish defense minister
saying this is why we decided to move
the Army closer to the border to scare
away the aggressor Russia's battle heart
and Wagner group has been training
belarussian soldiers reportedly at the
request of President Alexander
lukashenka troops have reportedly come
within five kilometers of Polish
territory since the training started
last month and on August 1st Poland
accused Belarus of illegally entering
its airspace
Russia's defense minister says the
militarization of Poland poses a risk to
run Russia several NATO countries along
the defensive group's Eastern flank
stepped up border patrols and
repositioned weapons following Russia's
full invasion of Ukraine nothing the
Polish prime minister says Russia and
Belarus are sowing chaos and unrest with
their veiled threats and recent actions
including cyber attacks not just against
Poland but Lithuania and Latvia we need
to be prepared for all kinds of possible
provocations also in the future for
Poland that means more manpower to
physically guard the Border in an effort
to keep the peace because an attack on a
NATO Nation would draw in all member
countries including Canada into the
conflict
Crystal gemancing Global News London